hey guys how's it going I'm Justine and
today we're gonna be baking one of my
favorite foods I'm a huge seafood fan
and ironically it is national seafood
month so in celebration I found this
really great recipe I printed it out
from Watt Alaska seafood coms you know
we're not messing around and today we're
gonna make some wild Alaskan cod so
these are actually frozen fillets and
after doing a small amount of research
I've never really worked with frozen
fish before so the proper way is to run
it under cold water Pat it dry with a
paper towel and then you're ready to go
let's do that first
[Music]
now in my directions it says that I've
got to cut up parsley cloves of garlic
some fresh lemon zest some things like
that but I'm not going to cut them up
I'm going to put them in a blender so if
you want to do the traditional way feel
free to cut away but I want to blend it
up hope for the best
so our final dish is gonna look a little
something like this it's gonna be this
lovely little Cod over a nice little bed
of asparagus not really sure if I'd ever
want to take a nap in asparagus it
doesn't look that comfortable but if
that's the bed that you want that's the
bed that we're gonna make and we've got
our asparagus which this is gonna be
Bowl that we're gonna put it in and
we're just gonna bake it right in this
thing I am gonna cut the asparagus cuz
it's real really no other way
I can't blend the asparagus I mean I
could but that's not how it was a little
oven it's currently being preheated to
450 I don't really know how to cut these
I'm just gonna cut it how I how it looks
in the restaurant when I get them I'm
just gonna make them fit in this bowl
there we go
that looks like a nice bed nice bed now
we'll make our little topping like I
said you could just cut this stuff up as
well but that's not how we're gonna do
it so I've got our olive oil get out our
lemon zest if you will I might have to
do a little bit of cutting been in there
four cloves of garlic never really had
garlic before so this is going to be
just interesting get out of there oh
gosh one clove garlic is it smells so
good do this might not be pretty hear
how I'm cutting this garlic but I'm
gonna get it done it'll get the job done
don't worry
oh I should probably add some salt and
pepper
that's working out pretty good
Wow yeah if you ask me
so place our fillets on top of their
nice little bed nice little siesta that
you guys are gonna take I'm gonna bake
you up just put this nice little glaze
[Music]
oh boy no let's put these in the oven
bye-bye
all right so it says to roast uncovered
20 to 25 minutes for frozen fillets
which these are frozen which is great
because you can get them at any time of
the year and 15 to 20 minutes from fresh
or thawed fish set 20 minutes on the
clock okay 20 minutes and Counting
perfect I'm gonna clean this up and I'll
see you guys in 20 minutes so my timer
just went off which means my water lots
of Cod is done roasting glowstick good
oh gosh oh boy oh it's very very very
hot look how delicious this looks I'm
impressed
it's like still sizzling
now let's plate this thing up this looks
so good
this looks incredible I am so proud I'm
so proud of myself now if I can just get
it out of here easily we're gonna be
golden oh by the time oh yeah I am chef
Justine Oh beautiful that's really
beautiful taste test time first let's
try two asparagus a lot really good
this actually looks like it is cooked
perfectly like if I went to a restaurant
this is what I'd get except I didn't
even leave my house I am so impressed
with myself like this tastes amazing
like I would go into a restaurant and
this is what I would order and they
would show up and it would be like hey I
made that I made this myself I am so
happy now I know if I'm ever out in the
wild I'll be able to survive as long as
I have an oven some frozen fish and some
quality ingredients we're set thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this video I've been having
so much fun kind of going outside of my
comfort zone with cooking so this was
actually pretty successful and it was
surprisingly so easy that the fact that
I don't cook more often for myself is
really ridiculous let me know if you
guys have any other suggestions for
things that I should make next and if
you guys happen to recreate this dish be
sure to tweet it to me posted on
Instagram and use the hashtag ask for
Alaska see you guys later
god this is delicious I want to ask me
some other questions feel free to leave
them in the comments below and legend
has it if you comment early I reply
first question we have here is from Bart
and he is asking if YouTube were to shut
down what would I do for my financial
income pretty interesting question
because I started YouTube for fun not
because it was a job